what's going on guys this is rob and
normally on wednesdays we cover the
ending of the what-if episodes and
explain it and make it make sense but
given the fact that the spider-man
trailer recently came out
i don't think anybody would fault me for
bypassing issue number three which or
really episode number three which
doesn't really need much explanation
anyway and going into spider-man so in
this video we're going to be answering
the question
who's controlling doctor strange right
because that's one of the things that a
lot of people are asking and you guys
have made some really really good points
looking at the trailer one of the things
that you notice about the mannerisms and
the overall attitude and behavior of
steven strange is that it's very
different from what we're used to steven
strange is very much an overly serious
character right a guy who just takes
himself super seriously and the fact
that he's kind of joking around that he
tells wong of course i'm not going to
cast a spell then winks of peter parker
it seems very uncharacteristic for
doctor strange now there's a couple
possibilities here the first one is that
marvel is making an adjustment to his
character in the same way they adjusted
thor that thor was very much a serious
character until you go into ragnarok and
then he's more of a comedic character it
could just be that kind of character
evolution i'm more of the opinion that
it really is steven strange but let's
say that it's the second option here
that it's the option that a lot of you
guys are going with which is that
someone is controlling steven strange
then the question has to be asked here
who's doing it who's controlling steven
strange and more so than that
why okay let's go with our first real
option here i mean there's a lot of
possibilities here right professor x of
the x-men is controlling steven strange
you guys suggest but during jonathan
hickman's new avengers run the
illuminati story you actually find out
that when reed richards gets the
infinity gauntlet right like mr
fantastic of the fantastic four when he
gets the infinity gauntlet he doesn't
want to put it down like the watcher
shows up and he's like read like
disperse the infinity stones none of you
should be in possession of the gauntlet
and he's so intoxicated with power he
doesn't want to put it down and
professor x of the x-men manipulates his
mind and gets them to put it down like
literally professor x overrode the power
of the mind stone right so you guys
suggest about the idea that like
professor x could be controlling doctor
strange but he could obviously that's
not a legitimate option here but it'd be
amazing if it was so here's the real
first person that i'm picking to be the
one who's controlling steven strange and
that is nightmare now nightmare i think
will be a pretty popular choice among
fans of the mcu and here's the reason
why people want to see them
that's really it people want to see
nightmare and the reality is this is
potentially something nightmare would do
the biggest problem with this is that
the way events are unfolding in
spider-man 2 it doesn't look like
something nightmare would do if he was
in possession of doctor strange so for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with this nightmare is what we call a
fearlord he's basically one of these
guys who exists in what's called the
splinter realms you guys know that in
the marvel cinematic universe you have
the realm of dormammu right well in the
comics it's very much the same way the
difference is that the dark dimension
was at one point in time a giant
landmass right so imagine that like like
all the continents on earth were at one
point a giant chunk of land which
technically they were it was called
pangaea that was the realm of dormammu
before he got there now after he got
there he conquered the whole area right
and then there was some kind of a
conflict or war that took place it's
never really explained to us but
basically a huge portion a pretty large
portion of the dark dimension basically
broke off into a series of smaller
realms which we call the splinter realms
and then you saw the rise of different
beings nightmare mephisto people like
that each of whom ruled their own little
section in the same capacity that like
if a person ruled the entire continent
of africa or asia or north america or
something like that that's kind of how
the splinter realms work right so uh
nightmare is a person who hails or a
being who hails from one of those realms
the big difference here is that
nightmare feeds on the the nightmares of
people it's how he sustains himself now
the more people there are sleeping the
more nightmare energy he can feed on the
more powerful he becomes more recently
in marvel comics he actually gained so
much power by feeding on the nightmares
of everybody who was asleep across the
entire world that he actually ended up
defeating all of the different cosmic
entities including the living tribunal
and that's where a lot of people are
getting the credence for the idea that
nightmare is the one who's controlling
doctor strange because in that comic he
captured doctor strange and then used
doctor strange to put the world to sleep
and then fed on all their energy for the
purpose of conquering seemingly all of
creation it's a legitimate possibility
the difference here is that if it really
was nightmare you likely wouldn't see
things unfolding in the way that you're
seeing them unfold in spider-man 3. what
you would be seeing is him basically
trying to put the world to sleep
starting with peter parker presumably
anybody else you wouldn't really see him
casting a spell that would allow for
some adjustment essentially to the
timeline that would result in basically
a breaking of the universe in relation
to the multiverse and just entering a
state of free fall you wouldn't really
see that right it wouldn't really be
something that nightmare would do
potentially it's something that our next
choice would do which is mephisto now
why are we choosing mephisto here
honestly because everybody wants to see
mephisto right the devil's in the
details right everybody's like mephisto
mephisto's confirmed right we still
haven't seen him yet here's the biggest
issue with that mephisto doesn't really
function in that capacity what mephisto
usually does is make bargains he makes
deals with people and then takes their
souls when the deals are done and then
also tricks them along the way here's a
really good example of that so there was
a story that was written recently called
thanos wins which is basically a story
where thanos seemingly conquers the
universe without using the infinity
gauntlet one of the first things he did
is he showed up on earth and destroyed
the avengers during that time the
punisher was so pissed off about what
happened he basically said he would do
anything to be able to destroy thanos
and so mephisto appeared and gave the
punisher the power of the ghost rider
here's the caveat because the punisher
had the power of the ghost rider he had
the power to kill thanos the issue is
thanos has long since left earth and
ghost rider can't leave the earth
because he doesn't have the power to fly
into space so it was basically mephisto
giving the punisher what he wants just
not the means to achieve it that's kind
of how ms fisto works now ultimately
frank castle ended up siding with
galactus he became his new herald and
then ended up becoming an ally of thanos
later on but the important thing is
that's usually how mephisto works what
would likely happen here if that were
the case is if mephisto somehow made a
bargain with doctor strange which i have
a hard time seeing how that would be a
possibility largely because there's not
really anything that doctor strange
wants so incredibly badly that he's
willing to make a bargain with the devil
to do it and even if he was he'd have to
be aware of what it means to make a deal
with mephisto just because of the mystic
nature of both of these guys they'd have
to be aware of the other and so assuming
that's not really what's going on and
doctor strange did make a bargain with
mephisto that mephisto would likely do
something like this right that it's
entirely possible he would do it just to
mess with things right just to have a
good time but even then it's still a
little uncharacteristic for him usually
when mephisto makes a deal with somebody
his endeavors and his engagements are
confined to that person the only real
major exception that you saw was during
the original infinity gauntlet story
when mephisto was trying to manipulate
thanos and then eventually get the
gauntlet from him and it was only for
mephisto trying to attain huge levels of
power and if that were the case mephisto
wouldn't really have doctor strange or
wouldn't really use doctor strange to
enter into the multiverse and cause all
kinds of problems instead he would
likely just try to find a way to conquer
all of creation so in truth it would
behoove mephisto to go after wanda more
than it would be to go after doctor
strange but nonetheless it is a
possibility here now the next choice
that i'm picking is one that i think is
actually really cool and would feed
directly into doctor strange too right
this guy is schuma gorath now shuma
gorath and dr strange have a long
history throughout the entirety of
marvel and we know that shumogorath is
going to appear in doctor strange too
the the indication here is that
shumogorath is going to be chasing after
america chavez because shumogorath is
likely trying to leave whatever universe
he happens to be in or that he's
currently occupying assuming they go
with that instead of him being a
multiversal character and then use
america chavez's abilities to jump
between realities as a means to expand
into the multiverse but say for example
that was the backup plan that the
initial plan of shumo gorath once he
became aware of the fact that the
multiverse had returned maybe he popped
up when the multiverse returned whatever
the case is he's looking to basically
expand into the rest of the universes
and conquer the entirety of the
multiverse which has really been the
motivation of his character all this
time and he comes across steven strange
and he realizes the level of power that
stephen strange has and then says well
i'll just conquer stephen strange right
i'll take over this guy and then go
forward accordingly and then in turn
when peter parker shows up and says i
need you to cast a spell that can
basically remove everybody's knowledge
of my existence then it's aha perfect
reason to basically find a way into the
multiverse right to screw things up
intentionally so everything going wrong
with regards to the spell and all that
kind of stuff is not necessarily because
of peter parker maybe it partially is
but it's really more schuma gorath
trying to find a way into the multiverse
again there's not a lot to go on there
right and even in reality that theory
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
when you think about the nature of
shumogorath it'd be a far more
intelligent endeavor and it would be
really much simpler if shumogorath took
over the body of doctor strange and then
worked his way outward and basically
started subjugating all the different
superheroes that existed on earth and
then worked his way out from earth into
the rest of the universe and then
basically conquered the universe and
then went out into the multiverse now
it's entirely possible he's already done
that in other universes and this is much
like it is in the comics where earth the
main marvel cinematic universe is just
the next place that he's trying to
conquer and steven strange is his way in
there but again it still begs the
question why would he go through all
this effort why would everything happen
in spider-man 2 unless it wasn't
supposed to happen unless peter parker
really did screw up and now everything's
kind of going awry but it is a
possibility honestly i think is a pretty
flimsy one i think the best candidate
for the person that is controlling
steven strange controlling the
mannerisms of steven strange
is wanda i think wanda's the best person
to do that and here's the reason why we
know just by virtue of the deleted post
credit scene for wand division
supposedly that little bit of a shadow
that you see kind of on the mountains
was supposedly steven strange traveling
to wanda now that has been analyzed and
in some ways discredited people saying
is this kind of a leftover fragment from
the original footage when it was
modified and so on and so forth but we
do know that doctor strange was supposed
to show up in one division we know that
right now agatha harkness is just out
there in new jersey or upstate new york
wherever that little town was and she's
just kind of trapped there living out
the life that wanda created for her so
we know juana does have the power to
subjugate other beings of magical power
that are very powerful in and of
themselves we also know from the end of
juan division the power of wanda exceeds
that of stephen strange now the question
has to be asked if that's the case why
would she subjugate stephen strange to
make sure he doesn't work against her
right it'd be the easiest and most
simple plot that if wanda was really
messing with the dark hold and that
stephen strange went to visit her and
said look you can't be doing this or
when she heard the cries of her kids
that she took off and instead went to
the sanctum sanctorum and told steven
strange hey here's what's going on a
couple things to remember here one
stephen strange is a sorcerer supreme i
have a very hard time believing he
didn't know anything about what was
going on and the great big huge fight
and everything going on with wanda
altering reality and all that stuff with
agatha harkness i have a hard time
believing he didn't know and it would
make perfect sense that either he
traveled to her or she traveled to him
but basically there was a kind of
discussion to be had there and that when
the idea was from at least from juana's
perspective i gotta go find my kids that
the the answer of steven strange was he
can't right like i know it sucks but you
can't you can't go meddling in the
multiverse like that you can't start
screwing things up you're gonna cause
problems and then if wanda's like well
no i'm going to anyway and steven
strange moves to stand against her
suddenly it's boom domination and
basically wanda takes over stephen
strange just to ensure that while she's
gone doing her thing steven strange
isn't going to act against her it would
explain why his mannerisms are different
here because if you look at the
mannerisms of steven strange in the
spider-man trailer he reminds me of
wanda right the winks and the little bit
of a kind of a goofy jokey nature to a
degree when she's happy right when she's
happy when she's chill not when she's
like losing her [ __ ] right not anything
like that when she's like pissed off and
angry or in like age of ultron nothing
along those lines but when it's just
wanda being wanda excited about what's
to come right it very much reminds me of
her and so it would make the most sense
that if a singular person were
controlling doctor strange that is wanda
who's doing it basically making sure
that he will never be able to do
anything that will work against her
while she's gone so he somehow chases
after her into the multiverse and
everything pops off having said that i'm
still not a huge fan of the idea that
anybody is controlling doctor strange i
think it really is just doctor strange
by himself i think it's just him he's in
full control of his faculties and
basically he was casting a spell peter
parker wouldn't shut the hell up and
everything went sideways i think that's
basically what happened you know in in
spider-man 3 with regards to that whole
segment and the multiverse and all that
kind of stuff but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
i'm really excited to hear what kind of
theories you guys have and uh yeah i
will catch you all later
peace